you testified yesterday that you sought
a temporary restraining order on may 27
2016 because you wanted to change your
locks do you remember that testimony yes
i do because the locks were to the
penthouse is at the eastern columbia
building isn't that correct that's
correct you changed the locks to the
penthouses on may 22nd 2016. i attempted
to
that's why you felt comfortable having
james franco over the evening of may
22nd 2016 miss heard
i do not know when
i do not know when james came over okay
let's remind you can we please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 304 which is already
in evidence and play
from 254 through 439
hmm
[Music]
you
uh
that's you and mr franco on may 22nd
2016 right miss heard that's correct and
you're taking him up to the penthouses
aren't you that's where i lived yes and
it's past 11 p.m at night isn't that
right i'm not quite sure the time it
looked it looked like that
why don't we pull that video back up
22 51
almost midnight right that's uh excuse
me almost 11 o'clock at night exactly
okay
you knew mr depp was out of town the
week of may 21 2016 didn't you
i don't know what i knew of his schedule
at the time
knew mr depp was out of town on may 27th
when you went to get the domestic
violence restraining order isn't that
right i don't know if i knew that at the
time
you knew you knew mr depp was heading
out on a european tour that week isn't
that right i'm not quite sure what i
understood of his schedule at that time
you knew he wouldn't be back for weeks
right no that's incorrect
let's uh go back to that recording
so defendants exhibit 598.
so you testified that
you and mr depp were in the car
outside of his studio is that right yes
you were trying to prevent him from
going into his studio to do drugs right
uh yeah to effectively start another
cycle right
not that mr depp was just trying to go
into his house to see his daughter right
his daughter might be one of the people
that was in the house at that time but
that's
neither here nor there though testimony
is now from entering a cycle
your testimony is now that mr dutt does
drugs in front of his children
well first of all i know he does
second of all
it wouldn't have mattered it wouldn't
have stopped him from using with his
friends which is the problem not whether
or not his daughter was there